a walking mass of human hair gel is
playing president again California gov
Gavin Newsome shaking hands with Chinese
president Chi while on a week-long tour
of China Newsome says he's trying to
find common ground on climate change
yeah right and says states have a duty
to act on global warming that's
important even if the federal government
does not America's top foe giving greasy
gav ar rousing welcome and even let him
cruise around in $ 160,000
Chinese EV don't run over protesters
this is a preview of things to come uh
and this we don't have yet in the United
States What I Hear around the globe is
well we you're not a reliable partner in
America what happens if Trump gets back
into office in a couple years what
happens if Biden loses we can't we can't
rely on you I want you to know you can
rely on California we're not going to
move the needle on climate change unless
the United States and China collaborate
together I wanted to substantively uh
work to to advance that effort and we
did so uh last few days the golden
states Michael Scott has made no secret
he's gunning for the top job before his
China Excursion Nome was out in Israel
and joked with reporters about the
limited scope of the trip telling them
quote I wish I was the president of the
United States I could start doing all
those things Jesse you know Gavin
reminds me of he's like the guy at work
who acts like he's your best pal but
then pitches your ideas to the boss when
you're not not around like me yes you
were the Cavin doome of fox oh don't say
that that'll catch on that will catch on
the hair stuff not that will catch on
China is grooming Nome and Nome is
enjoying being groomed yes this entire
country has turned against the Chinese
and and all of a sudden G Ping's like
you know what I'm gonna roll out the
carpet for that guy and what does that
guy do he goes up and he walks right
down to the red carpet with a big smile
on his face and shakes his hand
nationally this is political poison
because even Democrats are China Hawks
now the whole party both parties are
getting out of there and this guy he's a
California guy and he doesn't see it he
only sees EVS he only sees Tech and huge
economy in California it's the only
reason you're involved with China in the
first place so he just went there he
lapped it up and he's it's a practice
run and he's doing it right in Joe's
face yes oh Joe probably doesn't know
about it probably uh I hear EV stands
for extra Vaseline when it comes to
Gavin um he's not bothering to hide it
anymore Dana he's out there yeah and uh
Daniel turner He's with this group power
the future he said that Gavin Nome is
willing to travel all the way to China
to meet with Communists but he won't
meet with California's fossil fuel
workers who have lost their jobs due to
his policies and you're right on that in
terms of of Americans right now well 70%
of them are willing to pay more for
products that are not made in China so
read the room I'm really looking forward
to that Hannity debate between Hannity
um excuse me Nick n and DeSantis the
other thing was he was bragging about
how much time he's had with Xin ping and
then Biden was like well I've had time
with X ping too I'm like wait why why
are you competing about who is more
chummy with X ping what did I miss yeah
good point is it XII ping G oh I said
Chi who cares you know what who cares
it's not like I'm going to meet him
anytime soon judge uh it's true he can
travel all over the world but California
is still a mess
California is still a mess more people
are moving out of California than any
other state I mean they their homeless
population is is the highest in the
country and the drug overdoses are at an
all-time high looting and robbery is
running rampant and even in the nicest
towns and people are getting their butts
taxed I mean but nobody cares about that
this guy is either delusional or the
smartest guy I've ever met you see that
photo right there he's going to use that
in his campaign I don't know if he knows
something about Joe that none of us know
but this is all preparing for what he
wants to do I mean obviously the guy
wants to run for president but you know
I got to say one more thing that it's
that the the Jinping can buy you you are
so cheap you were so cheap that you
would sell American values and American
workers and fossil fuels and Factory
workers to go over there so that you can
look like a paid person and I won't say
what J
to sit there with Jing that's what you
are he bought off the bidens he probably
thinks he could buy off Nome too you
know uh Pi there's a lot of stuff going
on right now we got we're on the verge
of a war doesn't it seem a bit strange
to be talking about global warming when
the world's kind of on fire well it does
but I think what is also strange as a
part-time California resident is to see
probably the wokest governor in the
history of the United States so
bracingly and ecstatically sucking up to
the leader of mean is China shows me
that Nome has the ruthless streak it
needs to probably Chu Joe Biden under a
bus there was a funny moment today by
contrast if you're wondering whether Joe
Biden even knows what's going on here
what is the most famous quote in the
history of United States arguably I'll
suggest one Neil Armstrong on the Moon
one small step for man one giant leap
for mankind there's not a human being
alive who doesn't know that quote Joe
Biden did that quote today when he's
with the Australian prime minister
because Australian Engineers work worked
on the Luna Landing in in 68 Joe Biden
stood there and he said as the famous
quote said one small step for man one
small step giant step for mankind he
forgot the leap yeah so uh I think
you're dealing with somebody who
probably isn't even aware that new is
doing this Nim says I wish I was
president he's obviously going to run
for president if you're a Democrat you
you want him running for president you
don't want want Biden I honestly think
the only way the only way Trump probably
wins if he's the nominee personally
speaking is if Biden's his opponent yeah
especi if you get someone like newst
who's thr that ruthless street now he's
half his age he's got dynamism he's got
the charm he comes on Fox he's doing
debates with the santis you know he
should be the guy they put up I think
especially with Biden believing in the
moon landing whoa didn't happen hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else